all right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
Of course.
Questions submitted by you.
If you have questions that you would like
answered on this segment, just go to our website,
David pakman.com send an email using the contact
[inaudible]
first one.
Hey, David.
At this point, what could really be so bad
about what's in Donald Trump's tax returns
that he still is fighting so hard to prevent
their release?
Yeah, this is true.
I mean the guy's being impeached and there
are still all sorts of proceedings meant to
hide Donald Trump's tax returns.
I won't give you the full list of the different
mechanisms that have been attempted in order
to try to obtain those tax returns.
So let's go through the list from the beginning
that we speculated was the justification for
why Donald Trump didn't want his tax returns
released.
We'll talk about how likely each of them is,
but then also more importantly whether it
would still matter.
I think that the reason now Trump wants to
hide the tax returns is different than what
it was four years ago.
First, we speculated maybe Donald Trump doesn't
really make nearly as much money as he claims
to and or although tax returns wouldn't necessarily
show net worth, they would suggest that the
net worth Trump claims is likely overblown.
This could be a blow to Trump's ego.
Trump is obsessed with status and how he's
perceived and wants to be seen as rich and
all of this stuff.
That's one possibility.
The other possibility we speculated about
was that there would be liabilities or um,
uh, uh, entanglements exposed by his tax returns
that would be politically difficult for Trump.
One was, he's in huge debt to Russia.
He took money from Russia.
He's way more tied in with Russia, uh, than
he has admitted that may be at this point,
if that went public, I don't know that it
would really be very damaging to Trump.
It might be embarrassing to some degree, but
the Republican party at this point has a completely
bought hook, line and sinker the story that
there's nothing wrong with anything Trump
did with Russia.
Anytime Russia comes up, it's a witch hunt.
It was a hoax, whatever.
I actually don't think it would even be that
damaging if that was revealed, but that's
another possibility for what's in Donald Trump's
taxes.
The other possibility is that there will be
discrepancies, um, uh, made, made public between
Donald Trump's, um, uh, private claims or
claims for lending purposes about the value
of different assets and the ones that he claims
for tax purposes.
So you might, if you're using a certain, uh,
asset as collateral for a loan, when you apply
for the loan, you claim a much higher value
to make you look like a better, uh, lending
risk to the bank.
But for tax purposes, you want to minimize
the value of that asset in order to pay less
in taxes that depending on how the accounting
is done and how much of that stuff is on his
personal taxes anyway, you may or may not
be able to glean that from personal taxes.
In any case, it would be indicative of a crime,
I believe.
Because in New York city you're not allowed
to sort of have double books as it were, where
you value assets differently for different
purposes.
According to one accountant I spoke to, but
it sort of exceeds our scope.
And again, politically I think his followers
would just say that that's smart, that that's,
that's all that is.
There's speculation that maybe some kind of
other crime would be exposed by Donald Trump's
taxes.
I don't buy that at all.
If Donald Trump committed crimes that are
financial crimes, um, he has his, uh, professional
accountants prepare taxes.
I can't imagine that a professional accountant
would plainly expose that some kind of crime
has been committed.
There might be something that alludes to one
that would require more research and other
documents.
I think at this point, the real reason Donald
Trump is still fighting this hard to hide
his taxes are either number one, just because
of the income net worth thing.
To the extent you could glean it because of
his ego or it's just Trump doesn't want to
take the loss images.
What matters to Donald Trump?
If Trump wants his taxes to be private, Trump
wants to win the fight about keeping his taxes
private and there's really nothing for him
to gain by releasing them.
At this point.
It is only downside risk.
Even if we agree the risk isn't that great
that his followers would essentially justify,
rationalize anything that's in the taxes.
It's unlikely that there is an obvious crime
in the taxes and even if there is, Trump has
been completely Teflon when it comes to everything
that he's done that does or potentially breaks
the law.
I think now it's just downside risk.
There's no advantage to releasing the taxes.
Trump wants the win and that's mostly what
it is right now.
If you have a different view, let me know.